[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa soy santiago lópez gonzález este
es el espacio de france 24 en el que
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
del cob y 19 en nuestro continente a
continuación les presento el sumario de
temas que tenemos para hoy vamos a
comenzar en argentina allí este país
seguirán con restricciones y en
cuarentena así lo ha dado a conocer el
presidente alberto fernández quien
explicó los motivos para que este país
tenga ya una de las cuarentenas más
largas del mundo y no logra tampoco
disminuir el número de casos de contagio
tenemos todos los detalles por su parte
brasil superó los 5 millones de
contagios de kobe 19 el país
suramericano sigue siendo el más
afectado por la pandemia buena parte de
la población ha optado por retomar su
vida normal y dejar la crisis de lado
mientras que hay sectores médicos que
indican que el subdiagnóstico podría ser
mucho mayor de lo que se cree y mientras
tanto europa vive ya la segunda ola de
contagio en américa latina'
preguntándonos cómo afectará nuestra
salud mental si contemplamos la
posibilidad de volver a estar en un
confinamiento y tener restricciones de
movilidad cómo le está empezando a
suceder a europa vamos a analizar el
tema de la salud mental una llamada
segunda pandemia que nos trae la
pandemia del joven 19 lo vamos a
analizar en minutos
vamos a comenzar como ya lo decíamos
hablando de argentina para conocer cuál
es el panorama que se está presentando
allí ya son más de 850 mil casos
registrados y más de 22.000 personas
fallecidas hubo nuevos anuncios el día
de hoy por parte de la presidencia de
argentina en cuanto a las restricciones
para algunas de las regiones y para
mantener también algunas de las que hay
impuestas en la ciudad de buenos aries
la capital que es donde han estado
concentrados la mayor cantidad de
esfuerzos para luchar contra el kobe 19
también está sobre la mesa la
posibilidad de iniciar nuevamente las
operaciones de los vuelos de cabotaje o
vuelos domésticos o nacionales e incluso
retomar en cierta medida a las clases
presenciales pero tras el último anuncio
parece que argentina va a seguir
entonces confinada
tengo la convicción de que lo que
hicimos con el área metropolitana de
buenos aires- ahora tenemos que hacerlo
con cada provincia
lo que vamos a hacer es
y poner fin a lo que está sucediendo
allí en argentina cuéntenos natalio que
es lo que ha dicho el presidente en las
últimas horas con respecto a las medidas
que tiene que implementar algunas de las
provincias del país
qué tal buenas noches hace poco tiempo
que habló el presidente no mucho hablo
desde la casa rosada ya está instalado
ahí que la raza de gobierno y a ver
explicó que se va a extender esta
cuarentena que vencía el domingo hasta
el día 25 de octubre por dos semanas más
pero las condiciones cambian porque la
situación del país cambio que es algo
que también explicó si hacia mayo
aproximadamente estaba casi todo el
problema concentrado aquí en la ciudad
de buenos aires y en el área
metropolitana de buenos aires ahora se
ha trasladado al resto del país dijo que
el 65 por ciento de los nuevos casos
ahora están en el resto del país en mayo
es el número del 7,6 por ciento y
explicó sin dar demasiados detalles
todavía que serán ciudades de 18 de las
24 provincias del país las que deberán
mantener algún tipo de medidas de
aislamiento para tratar de frenar la
avanzada del virus entre esas ciudades
está la ciudad de buenos aires y también
el área metropolitana de buenos aires
entonces
vamos a ver cómo se va implementando
están este nuevo tipo de medidas que no
fueron especificados por el presidente
porque al mismo tiempo en estas regiones
se están dando nuevas aperturas como
bien señalaba por ejemplo en educación
hoy mismo también el jefe de gobierno de
la ciudad de buenos aires dijo que van a
empezar a partir el próximo martes a dar
algún tipo de actividad no todavía
específicamente educativa si al aire
libre para aquellos alumnos del último
año del secundario y del primario y que
también más adelante van a querer ir
incorporando al resto de los estudiantes
y hay otras provincias que también están
viendo de retomar las clases algunas ya
lo hicieron son las menos afectadas por
la pandemia pero al mismo tiempo que el
presidente anuncia algún tipo de
restricción que todavía no conocemos
bien se están anunciando nuevas
aperturas
natalio pues precisamente vamos a abrir
las palabras del presidente argentina
alberto fernández unas declaraciones que
dio desde la capital hace algunos
minutos esto fue lo que dijo
tengo la convicción de que lo que
hicimos con el área metropolitana de
buenos aires- ahora tenemos que hacerlo
con cada provincia
lo que vamos a hacer es
disponer en distintos departamentos de
18 provincias medidas que permitan una
disminución intensa y transitoria de la
circulación de personas durante los
próximos 14 días
yo le pido a todos a todos a todas
que por favor nos ayuden en esta etapa
que se inicia tenemos que restringir la
circulación eso no quiere decir que
vamos a parar el aparato productivo de
la economía quiere decir que los que no
tengan que circular que no circulen los
que puedan preservarse en sus casas que
se preserven
que todos entendamos que las reuniones
sociales son un riesgo enorme
lo que ustedes ven en tierra del fuego
es muy significativo a tal de un tema
que estuvieron mencionando los medios
argentinos fue la rey el reinicio de la
operación de los vuelos de cabotaje o
los vuelos domésticos porque muchas de
las provincias están pidiendo que por
favor restablezca en los vuelos para
estar comunicados con buenos aires de
una manera más rápida debido a las
grandes distancias que tiene argentina
por ser un país tan grande que es lo que
han dicho allí al respecto
bueno desde el ministerio de transporte
se dieron a entender que entre o sea la
semana que viene entre el 12 y el 15 de
octubre podrían comenzar nuevamente los
vuelos de cabotaje del interior del país
eso sí con la salvedad de que cada
provincia va a poder determinar con qué
condiciones y si acepta o no el regreso
de estos vuelos de cabotaje 24
provincias como bien decías en un país
muy muy grande muy extenso donde las
distancias son muy largas pero algunas
provincias todavía no están tan
convencidas y además cada una adoptará
sus propios protocolos para decidir que
le solicita a cada persona que ingresa a
la provincia con un vuelo de buenos
aires o de otra provincia si es que se
restablecen también los
interprovinciales en este contexto de
pandemias de todos modos
es hubo anuncios anteriores de posible
reinicio de vuelos y todavía no se
habían concretado entonces hasta que
esto no lo veamos en funcionamiento yo
creo que lo justo es esperar a que
efectivamente comiencen a volar y operar
estas líneas aéreas dentro del país
nuevamente natal de hablemos del nivel
de contagios ya usted nos mencionaba y
ya al presidente también lo mencionó
están aumentando los casos de contagio
en las provincias argentinas no
solamente buenos aires- es el caso
crítico que es lo que está sucediendo
allí entonces para que se vean fenómenos
tan particulares como la provincia de
tierra del fuego que es una isla que
está separada del argentina continental
es la provincia que más casos de
contagio está presentando en este
momento llama la atención que también
las provincias al otro lado de la
frontera en chile les está pasando lo
mismo
bueno tal vez sea un caso es difícil
saberlo pero también sea un caso
específico de una población pequeña y
muy concentrada del presidente si en su
alocución señaló que él cree que así lo
que se ha dado es un
y tal vez un relajamiento y un exceso de
reuniones entre personas reuniones
sociales y que puede tener que ver con
eso pero también es una población
pequeña concentrada en pequeñas ciudades
el problema tal vez más grande es que se
está dando un incremento en provincias
con mayor población como santa fe
córdoba y mendoza que son provincias muy
grandes y muy importantes del país y ahí
también se está dando un incremento
fuerte y problemático por ejemplo y ella
lo que menciona el presidente y es
preocupante que es que por ejemplo la
ciudad de rosario es una de las dos
segundas ciudades del país que es la
ciudad más importante de la provincia de
santa fe tiene un 96% de camas de
terapia ocupadas y esto se está dando en
varias ciudades importantes del país eso
es preocupante porque argentina hasta
ahora venían sosteniendo bien la
capacidad sin saturar del sistema de
salud y especialmente de las camas de
terapia si esto se lleva de mano se va
de control en estas ciudades puede
llegar a ser un problema importante
natalio muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad de buenos aires la
capital argentina contándonos cómo es la
situación en este país suramericano
vamos a seguir
en esta región porque brasil superó los
5 millones de casos y aunque los
expertos dicen que la cifra puede ser
mucho mayor a esto se suma también un
sentimiento que hay entre los ciudadanos
entre los brasileños de retomar la
normalidad de sus vidas y dejar de lado
esta emergencia esta crisis sanitaria
una suerte de anarquía en torno a la
pandemia de 1.019 algo que también
contrasta con las cifras 150.000
víctimas mortales dejó el coronavirus
solamente al inicio de esta semana este
es el panorama
otro día más en la unidad de cuidados
intensivos tratando a nuevos pacientes
de kobe 19 pero los médicos y enfermeras
tienen menos presión con el número de
nuevos contagios diarios disminuyendo no
sé si lo peor ha pasado porque no
sabemos lo que viene pero ciertamente
tuvimos peores momentos que ahora muchas
cosas han evolucionado desde el comienzo
de la pandemia tanto el número de casos
confirmados supera ahora la marca de los
5 millones en brasil el tercer país más
golpeado por la pandemia en el mundo
casi 150 mil pesos se han fallecido por
el coronavirus pero las cifras diarias
han bajado al menos un 70 por ciento
desde el pico en julio los expertos de
la salud dicen sin embargo que podría
haber muchos más casos no reportados
advirtiendo que es demasiado pronto para
relajar las medidas de distanciamiento
social
la primavera está aquí y las
temperaturas están subiendo eso impulsa
a la gente a reunirse en playas bares y
restaurantes me temo que veremos una
segunda ola de infecciones como en
europa
hacer una segunda onda se ve de ancho
por qué estado
mauro el presidente de brasilia air
bolsonaro ha minimizado repetidamente la
amenaza del virus y se ha opuesto a los
cierres los funcionarios locales también
han estado animando a la gente a volver
a sus vidas normales deseos de dar un
impulso a la economía que está
experimentando la peor desaceleración de
la que se tiene constancia las escuelas
públicas siguen cerradas pero varios
estados han anunciado planes para
reabrir las a finales de mes
vamos a conversar con valeria saccone la
corresponsal de france 24 en la ciudad
de río de janeiro hola valeria 5
millones de casos ya un poco más
registrados allí en brasil como acá esta
noticia entre los ciudadanos brasileños
y entre los integrantes del gobierno
mira curiosamente yo estoy notando
cierta frialdad me acuerdo que cuando
empezaron los primeros miles de muertos
en italia en españa los brasileños
estaban muy conmocionados incluso si
llegó a poner los colores de esa bandera
de mi cristo redentor que por las noches
suelen tener proyecciones y ahora hemos
superado esta semana a los 5 millones de
muertos y en la calle parece que no hay
una pandemia en curso además mañana se
van a superar oficialmente los 150.000
muertos que es otra barrera psicológica
y aunque las personas están preocupadas
bueno hay de todo hay personas que no se
pueden permitir la preocupación porque
con 13 millones de parados y 67 millones
de personas recibiendo un subsidio hay
que salir a trabajar pero también hay
muchas personas que salen para
divertirse los mares están llenos y
aunque por ejemplo las condiciones de
ruedas de samba que están prohibidas
oficialmente en la zona norte de la
ciudad el del 'green' suburbio las
favelas se siguen celebrando con actos
multitudinarios y los
no renuncian hace un divertimiento y
también en otras ciudades me llegan
noticias de más de lo mismo
galerías son 5 millones de contagiados
ya una cifra un poco superior allí en
brasil
ya usted lo está comentando esta
indisciplina de los brasileños que se
han pasado por encima las las leyes las
restricciones a la movilidad
esto está
mostrando que como que los brasileños
dejaron de lado la emergencia y para
ellos la vida empezó un nuevo rumbo
lejos del joven 19 que lo que pasa
bueno hay varias cosas que hay que
comentar primero los epidemiólogos esta
semana comentaron que habría que
multiplicar los datos por 6 o sea que en
realidad serían 30 millones de casos o
sea la población de muchos países
europeos por otra parte la gente es
verdad que como decía hay gente que
tiene que salir a trabajar a gente que
se ha relajado hay que recordar también
el papel del presidente de jair
bolsonaro que desde el principio
minimizó la pandemia habló que era una
gripe cita no observó la cuarentena
boicoteó activamente las medidas de
confinamiento de alcaldes y gobernadores
incluso cuando estuvo enfermo habló con
la prensa sin mascarilla entonces claro
en el momento en que hay mensajes
institucionales contrastantes de los
críticos locales versus el presidente de
la federación al mismo tiempo la
necesidad y el carácter un poco digamos
espontáneos de los brasileños que no les
gusta quedarse en casa valeria que hay
del sub diagnóstico ya usted lo estaba
mencionando también en su en su
respuesta anterior cuáles son los
motivos
en las autoridades al respecto
bueno la principal razón es que brasil
es uno de los países que realizan menos
tests de coronavirus del mundo entonces
nunca se compraron suficientes insumos
tampoco se han llegado a producir aquí
además no hay rastreadores como se han
puesto en algunos países donde si por
ejemplo tanto de asia como de europa
donde si por ejemplo estás infectado van
a buscar a todos tus contactos de los
últimos 15 días para aislarlos en casa y
luego repito este punto ligeramente
anárquico de desobediencia civil existe
me llegan relatos de primera mano por
ejemplo de personas que tienen al marido
en hospitalizado y que siguen haciendo
vida normal e incluso los feligreses de
su iglesia le visitan en casa para darle
confort o algo que contradice cualquier
sentido común y cualquier recomendación
de organizaciones como la organización
mundial de la salud
entonces se juntan muchos factores el
país es enorme hay 210 millones de
personas ha habido una gestión un tanto
contradictoria y en el fondo también hay
cansancio son siete meses están
comenzando el verano ahora tenemos en
este momento no hay lluvia de verano y
la gente no se quiere quedar más en casa
múltiples factores valeria muchas
gracias por este reporte desde la ciudad
de río de janeiro contándonos cómo está
el panorama en este país hablamos ahora
de méxico este país en registro a lo
largo de esta semana una cifra récord de
nuevos contagios por kobe 19 ya superó
los 28 mil casos nuevos casos
registrados y también las cifras de
muerte superaron ya la barrera de los 80
mil en toda la república mexicana las
cifras reales pueden ser mucho mayores
algo parecido a lo que está pasando en
brasil veamos
méxico superó las 80 mil muertes más que
un número esta realidad marca la
tendencia de que el país norteamericano
es el que tiene la mayor tasa de
letalidad del mundo es decir la mayor
cantidad de muertes por cada 100
contagios confirmados con 10,4 por
ciento las estadísticas de la
universidad johns hopkins muestran que
comparativamente los fallecimientos han
afectado a méxico por encima de países
como reino unido- ecuador irán y francia
esta realidad parecía distante el 18 de
marzo cuando murió por coronavirus la
primera persona en el país un hombre de
74 años que padecía diabetes pocos días
después el presidente de andrés manuel
lópez obrador invitó a los mexicanos a
salir a las calles desde un restaurante
en oaxaca
somos muy resistentes
todas las calamidades siempre hemos
salido adelante y en esta ocasión vamos
a salir adelante
el presidente americano también
recomendó abrazarse en contravía de los
lineamientos de la organización mundial
de la salud pero a medida que los
contagios crecieron hasta convertir a
méxico en uno de los países latinos con
más diagnósticos positivos
lópez obrador flexibilizó su disgusto
aunque nunca impuso un aislamiento
generalizado para todo el país si
comenzó a insistir en los cuidados
básicos en agosto méxico anunció junto
con argentina que produciría para toda
américa latina la vacuna que desarrolla
el laboratorio británico de astra set
pero el laboratorio pasó momentáneamente
sus ensayos clínicos por efectos
adversos en los pacientes que
posteriormente reanudó ahora méxico al
igual que el resto del mundo sigue a la
espera de la inyección mientras que sus
cifras demuestran que la pandemia no da
tres esta noticia también fue estacada a
lo largo de esta semana la rápida
recuperación del presidente de eeuu
donald trump ha tras haber sido
diagnosticado con kobe 19
al mismo tiempo continuaron
multiplicándose los casos de contagio el
interior de la casa blanca' así están
las cosas hayan washington
trump ha regresado a la casa blanca tras
ser internado por su contagio de kobe 19
pero todo se tornó diferente la sala de
prensa un lugar frecuentemente lleno de
personas se muestra sin reporteros allí
se observa el personal de limpieza bajo
fuertes medidas de protección
desinfectando el área y es que los casos
entre los allegados al donald trump
siguen en aumento
stephen miller uno de los asesores del
presidente fue el último confirmado por
kobe 19
trump también informado que otros
funcionarios republicanos están
afectados por la enfermedad para el
doctor anthony fauci el brote de la casa
blanca se habría evitado con controles
más estrictos y pues nada ya no se hizo
de acuerdo con las recomendaciones es
decir lo que se vio en la casa blanca
esa imagen desde arriba con todos los
aglomerados sin máscara seccionó se hizo
de acuerdo con lo que hubiera
recomendado dos meses tras su regreso a
la casa blanca- donald trump mantiene un
poderoso cóctel de drogas como
tratamiento pero ha señalado su
disposición de participar en el próximo
debate presidencial
joe biden su rival político pidió no
tomar el virus como un arma
y ha pedido que transmita el mensaje
correcto sobre la enfermedad
en lugar de hablar lo único que escuché
fue un tweet que decía no te preocupes
por todo esto hay mucho de qué
preocuparse 210 mil personas han muerto
respecto al debate sostiene que este
evento debe cancelarse dato el contagio
del presidente
vamos a seguir hablando de eeuu y del
presidente de donald trump y de su
recuperación de kobe 19 todo esto ha
sido un tema de conversación y de
noticia a lo largo de la semana nosotros
aquí lo reportamos en france24 porque el
mundo entero estaba haciendo el
seguimiento de la salud del presidente
porque no solamente es el mandatario de
la potencia económica del mundo sino
también porque el cantidad es candidato
del partido republicano y debería
enfrentarse en unos pocos días a un
debate político frente a su adversario
el demócrata joe biden es decir la
pandemia del cobe 19 logró permear no
sólo como tema de campaña sino también a
los candidatos durante su
hospitalización habló sobre la lección
de vida que le estaba dejando haber sido
diagnosticado con kobe 19 el mandatario
también invitó a los estadounidenses a
no tenerle miedo al coronavirus unas
declaraciones que fueron criticadas por
supuesto por diferentes sectores
políticos no solamente en eeuu sino
también en otros países porque esto daba
una señal de desconocer un poco más esas
cerca de 200.000 personas son más de
doscientas mil personas que han
fallecido en estado
por kobe 19 a lo largo de estos siete
meses que lleva la pandemia en el
continente americano el mandatario se
mantuvo muy activo en las redes sociales
publicó varios mensajes en su cuenta en
twitter también publicó varios vídeos en
los que hablaba de su situación de cómo
estaba siendo tratado hablo
particularmente de el tratamiento que
estaba recibiendo por parte de los
médicos de cabecera de la casa blanca'
un tratamiento que también fue muy
controvertido porque parte del protocolo
médico que recibió el mandatario el cual
también comentó a través de las redes
sociales no ha sido avalado por la
administración federal de alimentos y
medicinas la sda por sus siglas en
inglés que es la que debe oficializar
estos protocolos
el prácticamente el presidente fue un
paciente experimental de este protocolo
y pues tal parece según como lo indica
la casa blanca y sus médicos de cabecera
el mandatario pues se recuperó
rápidamente donald trump hasta salió del
hospital en algún momento solamente para
saludar a sus seguidores en uno de los
carros oficiales un acto muy criticado
por comprometer no solamente su salud
sino también de las personas de
seguridad y por aprovechar
su enfermedad con fines políticos así lo
criticó joe biden como ya lo decíamos el
candidato demócrata que criticó durante
este fin de semana en la forma de actuar
del presidente de donald trump
tan pronto regresó a la casa blanca ya
veíamos las imágenes hace un momento lo
primero que hizo el mandatario fue
quitarse la mascarilla e instó a los
ciudadanos a salir a llevar su vida con
tranquilidad a no tenerle miedo al cob y
19 a llevar una vida más tranquila esto
cuando estados como por ejemplo
california texas florida carolina del
norte illinois y wisconsin están
registrando altas tasas de contagio esto
de cara a las elecciones presidenciales
que están previstas
para el 3 de noviembre también la
situación ha estado complicada en el
estado de nueva york que en un principio
fue el foco de contagio en la unión
americana veamos el reportaje
como una señal de victoria o de
escepticismo frente al kobe 19 el
presidente de donald trump se quitó la
mascarilla tras llegar a la casa blanca
pese a que todavía no está fuera de
peligro según dijeron sus médicos
aprendí mucho acerca de coronavirus y
una cosa es segura no dejen que los
domine no le tengan miedo van a vencer
y ahora estoy mejor y quizás soy inmune
el mandatario publicó este mensaje en su
cuenta de twitter y aquí se ve como
interactúo con un grupo de personas
durante varios minutos para producir el
vídeo mientras permanecía sin mascarilla
la actitud de trump calificada de
irresponsable se ha dejado ver
repetidamente en esta oportunidad que
instó a sus ciudadanos a salir a las
calles y el domingo dejó brevemente el
hospital walter reed para saludar a sus
seguidores y que no resuelva no se puede
engañar sobre ciertas cosas y no digo
que lo hayan hecho si de hecho el
presidente había realmente contraído el
virus y lo sabía antes de salir en
público ya sabes los encuentros y no
llevaba una mascarilla eso es otra cosa
cualquiera que contraiga el virus
diciendo que las mascarillas no importan
que el distanciamiento no importa creo
que es responsable de lo que les pasa
que es con este comportamiento trump
llega a una casa blanca donde el virus
sigue propagándose principalmente entre
quienes asistieron a la ceremonia de
nominación de la jueza emmy con ibarra a
la corte suprema- los casos más
recientes fueron la secretaria de prensa
del presidente y dos de sus asistentes
eeuu ya superó las 210 mil muertes por
kobe 19 y el número de contagios se
acerca a los 7 millones y medio
vamos ahora a nuestra sección en redes
veamos otras noticias destacadas a lo
largo de la semana y comenzamos en perú
allí el aeropuerto internacional jorge
chávez que sirve a la ciudad de lima la
capital de ese país reanudó los vuelos
internacionales un avión procedente de
la ciudad de santiago la capital de
chile fue el primer vuelo comercial en
llegar a la capital peruana después de
casi siete meses de cierre de fronteras
el reinicio de estas operaciones viene
acompañado con un estricto protocolo de
medidas de bioseguridad las autoridades
peruanas dijeron que se iniciaban
solamente los vuelos a algunos países
vecinos como colombia ecuador bolivia
paraguay uruguay chile y mexico
también indicaron que es solamente serán
para vuelos que no superen las 4 horas
de duración que esto
requiere pues un protocolo mucho más
sencillo para el tratamiento de los
pasajeros y esta es una medida que busca
reactivar el centro de conexiones que es
el aeropuerto de lima que es un
importante punto para generar ganancias
en términos económicos recordemos que
perú está pasando por una de las
construcciones económicas más fuertes de
la región de suramérica debido a la
pandemia del cobi 19 y la reactivación
de los vuelos internacionales puede
generar alguna algunos movimientos
económicos y sobre todo empezar a hacer
la antesala para una reactivación de la
industria turística que es sumamente
importante en ese país pasamos ahora a
panamá y el ministerio de salud dio a
conocer esta semana la reglamentación
para la reapertura de cines teatros
bibliotecas hoteles y algunas
actividades turísticas y también el uso
de algunas piscinas entre ellas algunas
piscinas públicas el gobierno panameño
también permitió la apertura de los
museos las galerías de arte y los sitios
de importancia turística como por
ejemplo el casco antiguo de la ciudad de
panamá aún así se mantienen algunas
excepciones como algunos toques de queda
y algunas cuarentenas estrictas que han
sido impuestas en algunas provincias de
ese país hay que recordar también que
panamá restableció también los vuelos
internacionales hace poco panamá es el
centro de conexiones más importante de
la región
y esto ha permitido unir al centro y sur
y norte américa a través del joven que
existe en el aeropuerto internacional de
tocumen también una medida que fue
puesta en marcha para empezar a
reactivar la economía de panamá pasamos
ahora a trinidad y tobago allí
preocupación por el alarmante incremento
de los casos de contagio de kobe 19 en
la principal prisión de la isla de
tobago que es la segunda isla que
conforma este archipiélago 24 casos
nuevos fueron registrados en solamente
24 horas pueden ser una cifra que para
algunos países sea menor pero dada la
cantidad de personas que tienen las
cárceles de trinidad y tobago y la
población de ese país es una cifra
significativa cinco de estos casos serán
funcionarios de este presidio y 13 eran
prisioneros este archipiélago que está
ubicado en la costa frente a la costa de
venezuela registra más de 4 mil 800
casos ya confirmados en las dos islas y
presenta 80 fallecidos al inicio de la
pandemia las islas de trinidad y tobago
eran consideradas como uno de los países
en américa
estaba llevando de la mejor manera en
las medidas para evitar la expansión del
joven 19 en las últimas semanas incluso
lo reportamos aquí en el programa la
preocupación ha aumentado debido al
rápido incremento de los casos
particularmente en tobago y en la
capital del país la ciudad de puerto
españa
y nos vamos ahora hasta la isla de cuba
las autoridades anunciaron la apertura
de la isla al turismo internacional a
partir de la próxima semana en un nuevo
paso de avance hacia la denominada nueva
normalidad cuba cerró sus fronteras a
por espacio de seis meses recordemos lo
una decisión que afectó la industria
turística que es el principal pilar de
la economía cubana recientemente también
fue levantado el toque de queda en la
ciudad capital la ciudad de la habana
que si bien permite ahora los ciudadanos
moverse dentro de la ciudad hay ciertas
restricciones para las personas que
quieran salir o ingresar a la capital
desde y hacia las provincias cubanas
esto fue lo que dijeron allí en la
habana revienta tercera fase que se
actualiza
se abre en todas las provincias ya que
llega a esta fase la posibilidad de que
arribe en vuelos internacionales ahora
cuando llegue se la hace el pcr tanto un
extranjero como un cubano extranjero va
para su hotel y ahí va a estar siendo
observado hasta que se compruebe el
resultado que no estaba positivo y no
obstante eso hay un protocolo durante
toda su estancia que los tapes quizá mos
y en medio de un año atípico por el
aplazamiento de los juegos olímpicos de
tokio un grupo de velocistas colombianos
avanza con su preparación para esta cita
deportiva la pandemia ha marcado su
entrenamiento pero ha conseguido avanzar
con sus rutinas de entrenamiento
hablamos del equipo de relevo masculino
y mixto de este país cafetero que quiere
hacer historia en la capital japonesa
veamos
son parte de la élite del atletismo de
velocidad de sudamérica ahora reunidos
en bogotá para un entrenamiento con
altura del alexander gilmar jennifer
diego antón y lina integran un proyecto
de colombia que dirige el experimentado
entrenador cubano nelson gutiérrez con
la ilusión de brillar en el relevo
masculino y mixto en los juegos de tokio
queremos seguir soñando con una medalla
la idea es esa o sea no lo vamos a
cambiar realmente vemos vamos a ver cómo
se va desarrollando toda la preparación
hoy por hoy ya podemos trabajar ya
tenemos otra otra esperanza en el
trabajo sostenido anthony zambrano
sorprendió el mundo el año pasado con
una plata en el mundial de atletismo de
doha en los 400 metros planos el equipo
terminó en cuarta plaza un gran momento
que se congeló con el aplazamiento de
los zuecos ya yo que venía de hacer
segundo en un mundial venía con mucha
ansiedad muchas ganas de ser finalista
olímpico pero toda la semana divertido
como que la ilusión ni nada eso me ha
sido como que más fuerte porque yo
siento que eso fue como como una barrera
como un obstáculo
la pandemia ha marcado su preparación
unos pudieron ir a entrenar un tiempo a
lisboa otros recibían instrucciones de
manera virtual ahora este año termina
con una aparente normalidad este año
digamos que pese a lo duro ha sido más
bien para enseñarnos y nos ha permitido
enfocarnos en lo que realmente queremos
bueno se nos dio la posibilidad de estar
en europa
entrenando y a bueno ahora estamos aquí
continuando la preparación y con mucha
ilusión ha sido muy difícil porque creo
que cada uno de nosotros tenía una meta
tenía como que su su visión y su
ambición de mejorar en lo personal se
alejó un poco nuestro sueño pero sigue
intacto
compiten en una categoría que no es una
especialidad de la región y ante unos
rivales de europa en norteamérica que
han tenido más facilidades para entrenar
en la pandemia pero el camino a tokio
aún no ha terminado
bueno pues lo que nos deja la elección
de ellos es la oportunidad en medio de
la adversidad la adversidad de esta
pandemia del hobbit 19 es todo por el
momento en este resumen semanal de kobe
19 la semana en américa recuerde que
usted puede dejar también sus
comentarios sus opiniones o volver a ver
el programa a través de las redes
sociales en france24 punto com en
nuestra cuenta en twitter en facebook y
también descargando la aplicación en su
teléfono móvil es todo por el momento
nos vemos la próxima semana